last week I told you that breastfeeding
in public had been legally affirmed in
50 states with I think was Idaho and
Utah which were the holdovers that are
the holdbacks that hadn't yet done that
one caller known to us as the Texas
troll is not at all pleased with the
idea of me affirming public
breastfeeding take a listen to this
David I really don't think it's too much
to ask for women just to go to the
bathroom to breastfeed their children it
just doesn't really make much sense to
me just you know go into a private place
to do it I mean do you really think it
should be legal for a woman just to take
her shirt off on an airplane and start
breastfeeding I mean with her Tatas
hanging all over the place
you really think that's okay really have
some decency man that's disgusting
yeah um first of all I mean just as a
purely practical matter have you ever
seen a breastfeeding woman just take off
her top when when she's going to
breastfeed I've actually never seen ever
happen to me no no that that's just not
the way it works and number two you're
you're saying it should be against the
law to do that that how is that even
remotely logical I mean can't you just
look away too
I understand how it could maybe make you
uncomfortable like if you're sitting
next to a woman on a plane who's
breastfeeding but just deal with it
right look away do something else right
how is this worthy of even a call to a
program to say that it's disgusting that
this really seems like a person who has
bigger issues I would imagine than
somebody breastfeeding in public and it
this is exactly what I'm talking about
even though to so many of us it's
obvious that this should not be a legal
issue I've got people calling in and
saying David how dare you think it's
legal for a woman to breastfeed in
public and expose a breast how how on
earth would I determine that it should
be illegal that's what seems actually
actually crazy or even nipple man free
absolutely we've got a great bonus show
for you today
become a member at WWE pokémon calm to
instantly access the bonus show you can
also get access by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show